i'm getting to go on a guided tour of
mars this is so freaking cool
you can see this spectacular panoramic
landscape
this could be canyonlands this could be
death valley
what's the weather like in this section
of mars
yeah the the forecast for tomorrow is
just like the forecast for yesterday in
general
and like the forecast is has been every
day for billions of years
no chance of rain uh tonight's
temperature is going to dip down to
maybe minus 100 degrees celsius
minus 200 change fahrenheit
but tomorrow it's going to be a balmy uh
maybe plus three
celsius that's planetary scientist
jim bell he's taking me on the most
unusual guided tour i've ever been on
along mars's gale crater courtesy of
images from the rover curiosity
it's currently beaming back photos from
the red planet
the view is gorgeous the color of the
landscape reminds me of petra
the ancient site in jordan and its
beautiful rose-colored sandstone
the sky looks like a silvery very light
blue
but that's thanks to the photo white
balancing it's almost as if we were
standing on the surface
those beautiful pictures i was talking
about that we've taken from rovers and
landers that make it look like
well this would be a cool hike somewhere
in the desert southwest right well
that's all wrong
i mean it's you die in so many ways so
fast
if you're out there not attempting
prospect
but that hasn't stopped humans for
millennia from imagining themselves
or some other life form as living on the
red planet
nasa's next mission to mars hopes to
find out if life has ever been
or can be possible there
it's january 2021 and as i record this
the latest rover perseverance is heading
to mars
those crunchy noises they are the sounds
recorded by a microphone aboard
perseverance
picking up the whir of the rover's
thermal system as it hurtles through
deep space
at a speed of more than 50 000 miles per
hour
this mic and perseverance's
sophisticated camera system
are part of a suite of equipment that
promises to reveal more about mars
ancient past
and present than any previous mission
i'm amy briggs executive editor of
national geographic history magazine
and you're listening to overheard a show
where we eavesdrop on the wild
conversations we have at nachio
and follow them to the edges of our big
weird beautiful world
this week we hitch a ride aboard the
perseverance rover
sort of and learn how its elaborate
cameras are ready to get our closest
ever look at the red rocks craters and
canyons of an ancient delta on mars
its mission to seek out signs of past
life
collect samples for return to earth on a
future mission and explore the martian
climate and surface to see if humans
might one day
make a trip to the red planet
[Music]
imagine we're in ancient egypt sometime
during the reign of queen hetchetzop
roughly 3 500 years ago the egyptian
astronomer
cinema scans and studies the southern
and northern skies and begins to
painstakingly create a map
his map is one of the earliest pieces of
evidence of our fascination with mars
thousands of years later mars's position
in the night sky helped another
scientists attempt to map the surface of
mars
sorry our lights just flickered i don't
know if you saw that
what's happening here to find out how
i catch up with national geographic
contributor nadia drake
it's a bit tricky though we're in the
middle of new york city's first
snowstorm when i reached her
nadia covers space planetary science
astrophysics
as she says everything that doesn't
really happen on earth
she also happens to be the daughter of
renowned astronomer and astrophysicist
frank drake there was one really
influential map
that was produced in 1877
by giovanni scapirelli and
the reason why they were doing it at
that time was because
mars was at opposition meaning that it's
directly opposite the sun in earth's sky
so it's it's brightest and it's at its
closest point
um in the two planets orbits and so they
could see it the best but i needed to
know
why were early astronomers so fascinated
by a planet that they couldn't see all
that well
you know as one of the scientists i
talked to said it's just blank enough
that we can populate it with our
imaginings it doesn't push back
all that hard even now
my guess is jim bell appreciates the
laxity oh
and it's time for a proper introduction
so for our listeners please introduce
yourself by saying your name and what
you do
sure my name is jim bell i'm a
professor in the school of earth and
space exploration at arizona state
university
and i'm a planetary scientist
kind of a mixture of an astronomer and a
geologist
to be clear jim bell has lots more in
his toolkit than the egyptian astronomer
cinema
but his interest in space science was
also sparked by looking at the sky
i grew up in a relatively rural area
that had
nice dark skies and my family
got me a good telescope when i was 10
years old or something like that
i'd schlep it outside and see stars and
galaxies and the moon
and the rings of saturn and it was just
so cool
jim began digitally imaging the moon
mars and other planets while in grad
school
he graduated just as nasa restarted its
mars exploration with the pathfinder
mission
it was in the mid 90s
and uh was the first rover on mars about
the size they
can't see me on the podcast but about
the size of a laser printer or a
microwave oven a little rover called
sojourner and uh that's how i i got
involved they you know the team needed
folks with digital imaging experience
and i went from this you know kind of
fuzzy telescope view to z
right down on the surface of individual
rocks and sand grains you know
it was like wow it was crazy um and
and i just got hooked
since then jim has been heavily involved
in several nasa exploration missions to
mars
including with rovers spirit opportunity
and curiosity
he's now the principal investigator of
mast kmz
the main eyes aboard the perseverance
rover
it's never a routine day to land
something on another planet
uh you know we kind of take these things
for granted because nasa's been so
successful but not all of them
so of course you're biting your nails
and you're you know
when i when i watch them launch and when
i watch them land i
have written about this i describe it as
wanting to dance
and throw up at the same time
it's nerve-wracking that's quite a
visual
it almost makes you wonder why anyone
would sign up for this
but it seems mars has this way of
sucking people in
which gave way to a whole life on mars
movement nadia explains
there was the work of percival lowell
who was mapping it and was absolutely
convinced that he was seeing
this planet spanning network of
irrigation canals that were
constructed by intelligent martians and
those stories really took off
and so by the turn of the 20th century
if you thought that mars was populated
by
intelligent aliens there was a pretty
good reason for thinking that
that's not crazy now of course we know
that that's not the reality at all
because over the last hundred years
we've
gotten a really good look at the
planet's surface and we know
we know what it looks like
more on that in a moment
so the photography of mars actually
happened pretty early on
before 1910 and that was essentially
what
undid lowell's theories because people
could see
that the image of mars taken through
telescopes
didn't match the maps it turns out it
didn't match our imaginations either
telescopes then the first photos of mars
from space
courtesy of a flyby spacecraft dashed
all hopes of a planet teeming with
little green men
in july 1965 nasa's mariner 4 flew
within some 6 000 miles of the martian
surface
snapping the first close-ups of the
planet it returned
photos of a landscape that looked
cratered and dead
desolate sterile it looked like the moon
[Music]
it almost seemed as if those pictures
cratered our interest in further mars
exploration
but something out of the clear blue sky
reawakened that curiosity
i mean that quite literally scientists
found what
some of them believed was evidence for
fossilized microbial life in a meteorite
a martian meteorite that had been
recovered in antarctica
and in the allen hills so the meteorite
is called alh
84001 which i always feel really cool
when i say that
it's like i know it and what happened
was that they were
looking at this mars rock and saw this
little wormy thing
that looked like it could be a
fossilized microbe it looked like a life
form
it was 1996 and that discovery of
microscopic fossilized bacteria found in
a meteorite
made its way into a major scientific
paper and then into headlines
and into a speech by then president bill
clinton
more than 4 billion years ago
this piece of rock was formed as a part
of the original crust
of mars after billions of years
it broke from the surface and began a 16
million year journey
through space that would end here on
earth i am determined that the american
space program
will put its full intellectual power and
technological prowess
behind the search for further evidence
of life on mars
no matter that scientists questioned the
findings it still debated in scientific
circles
and gave the mars exploration program a
second wind
and so we started launching more
spacecraft going to mars to try and
figure out
once more if the planet was ever
habitable
by our standards did it have the things
that we consider necessary for life
to evolve and thrive
and if so was it ever inhabited and
those are the questions that we're still
really
asking we kind of put the first one to
bed we know that mars was
habitable by our standards but now the
question is did anything ever move in
[Music]
so i started this episode by talking
about the curiosity rover which landed
on mars on august 6
2012. it's still on the planet surveying
the gale crater
analyzing drill samples and tweeting the
cutest selfies
curiosity is kind of like the older
sibling of perseverance
perseverance is in a lot of ways like
the curiosity rover in another way is
very different
uh it's like curiosity because it's
built from about 90
spare parts from curiosity this is how
nasa could afford it
you know you don't just build one hey
let's hear it for redundancy that's
wonderful
yes yes and so on the outside it looks a
lot like curiosity on the inside and in
detail and in its mission
it's very different curiosity is
exploring
an ancient crater where from orbit we
thought there might be signs that of
habitability on mars in the past that
tell us that mars was a habitable world
and perseverance will do something
similar in another
ancient environment a crater called
jezero crater
that is uh it's not that big it's sort
of a connecticut size
crater and um but it has a beautiful
river valley that flows into the florida
crater with this spectacular delta
like like at the end of the mississippi
river or the mekong river
it's beautiful delta and it's all dried
up now of course it's all ancient
it's been pockmarked with craters but a
long time ago
early in mars history it was warmer it
was wetter there was
a river flowing down this crater wall
depositing sediments
in this much more earth-like environment
and so that's where we're going to send
perseverance
more on that mission in a moment
[Music]
go atlas go centaur go mars 2020
eight seven six five
five four engine ignition two
one zero
related and liftoff as the countdown to
mars continues
the perseverance of humanity launching
the next generation of robotic explorers
to the red planet
that was the launch of perseverance on
july 30th 2020
it's the latest step after years of work
by teams of scientists looking to answer
the age-old question
of whether life has ever existed on mars
and while we count down to february 18th
the day perseverance is scheduled to
land on mars
nothing is assured when i take a step
back and i
think about what this rover means this
rover is
you know all those late nights studying
as a student
it's all of the late nights in the lab
working with my co-workers trying to
figure out a problem
christina hernandez has joined us now
she works at nasa's jet propulsion
laboratory in southern california
she's been working on perseverance which
she calls a
one-ton robotic beast of a martian
explorer as a payload systems engineer
and what that means is i'm a jack of all
trades i get to work
on the the design uh the build the test
and eventually the operations over seven
different instruments on the rover
christina has worked at jpl since 2013
but this is the first project of hers
that's made it into space
this rover is the sacrifices that my
family and friends
made you know to allow me to work you
know seven days a week nearly 24
7 just to get the job done and
this rover it's the faces of all my
co-workers
all the people that i interacted with
the scientists the engineers
and and the business folks the the the
schedulers just
everybody who put helped put this
together
and when i think about the science
objectives it's
surreal
perseverance's science objectives will
be carried out by a suite of seven
instruments aboard the rover we talked a
little bit about mastcam z
the main system that will image the
planet with panoramic and stereoscopic
cameras
there's a second camera supercam that
can do chemical analysis
in addition to imaging other high-level
imaging systems aboard perseverance
include pixel
and sherlock then there's meta a weather
suite
rimfax a ground penetrating radar and
moxie
which can produce oxygen from carbon
dioxide on mars
mind-boggling stuff as a payload systems
engineer
christina focused her efforts on three
of the seven instruments
so it's best to let her explain how they
work together
the best example i could give is you
know say we are we've landed
right we're on the delta and mass cam z
will take this beautiful panorama on the
first few souls of mars
and that's going to tell the scientists
we want to go
left we want to go right we want to go
straight and all of the other instrument
teams are going to be using that imagery
to say huh like
how does this correspond to the the
first science bits of information that i
got down from the vehicle
maybe meta will say it was you know a
little bit windier than they expected
uh sherlock has um the watson camera and
that watson camera is kind of like
pixel and the other instruments close up
context camera because it kind of you
know if you think about that magnifying
glass to kind of get up close
and so it's really those those first
images that
give you the kickstart of the science
that you're going to be able to take at
a particular location
so it almost seems like there's an order
of operations where
you know you have the camera you know
zooming around and being like hey
there's a there's a there's a target
and then you have all the other little
superpowers coming out and analyzing it
before anybody makes a decision to go
dig a hole
where to you know analyze absolutely i
actually just got an image of avengers
end game with like all the superheroes
like coming out like
preparing for battle like that's really
what it is right yup
i was thinking this is i'm gonna date
myself i was thinking of the super
friends
and the hall of justice and like they
all hang out there and depending on
which villain attacks like that's who
they send out
i love it i love it
we'll have to wait for perseverance to
land to see what mind-blowing images it
might beam back
but for the crew the work continues even
while the rover is cruising through deep
space
and christina is preparing for her first
experience as a martian
so our prime mission is um one year on
mars which is roughly
you know two earth years and what's
really cool
in this concept of you know being a
martian
um for the first few months will
actually be on this thing called
mars time so we're gonna align ourselves
with the time zone that the rover's in
eventually we lose sync with
you know our earthling friends um but
you know we become martians for this you
know short period
i had no idea yet that that you are
you're right
you're literally going to be experienced
mars in the closest way possible
i know some families they you know
completely switch
over together and so that's something
i'm going to talk to my husband about
because we're working from home i was
like do you want to go on mars time with
me
he might not be too happy about that
though
[Music]
meanwhile i want to get back to my own
journey on mars
thanks to perseverance's predecessor
curiosity
[Music]
back in a moment
[Music]
so back to that tour i'm with planetary
scientist jim bell
touring the gale crater the landscape
while baron
is breathtaking no vegetation
uh cloudless sky spectacular hills
slowly eroding away in the background a
couple of
channels from where water once flowed
long ago
flat plains with bedded layered rocks
that are the
we learned later the ancient floor of a
of a water-filled lake this this scene
was a
was a crater lake at one point in time
three four billion years ago we're
looking at gale crater now where is that
in um in relation to where perseverance
will be landing
yeah gail is it's not too close it's uh
it's just a little bit south of the
equator
um and um perseverance is going to be
landing north
of the equator near a uh a very famous
feature to telescope observers through
the history of telescopes
that dark large dark area called certain
major
that's it's been seen since the 1600s
some of the first telescope drones so it
was one of the first features i've ever
seen
i mentioned earlier that the color of
the silvery blue sky was achieved with
white balancing
but while i'm on this tour of mars i
needed to know what it really looks like
it's an artistic choice almost on how to
portray
these colors there are versions of these
kinds of panoramas in more natural mars
color
and the sky generally is pink it's been
described as pink
it's been described as salmon it's been
described as butterscotch
and it changes it changes with time of
day
it changes from day to day as dust
storms come and go just like earth's sky
on mars there's always dust in the
atmosphere the atmosphere is so
thin that if there were no dust the sky
would be black like on the moon
i'm curious what would be your dream
discovery from perseverance
like shoot the moon what is it
the dinosaur femur no
nobody thinks that's going to happen uh
it's just the environment has been too
hostile for
macroscopic life like on earth to be on
that surface
for long enough to evolve as it has on
the earth
the odds are stacked against us for that
kind of thing
on mars however
mars doesn't care about the odds nature
doesn't care about the odds
nature freaks us out and surprises us
all the time
[Music]
back in a moment
[Music]
want to learn more about mars check out
our magazine story about the launch of
the perseverance rover
and its science goals also an explainer
on the history of mars exploration
and interactive about mars climate
history and odds of habitability
that's all in the show notes right there
in your podcast app
overheard at national geographic is
produced by carla wills
brian gutierrez jacob pinter laura sim
and alana strauss our senior editor is
eli chen
executive producer of audio is d'var
artillant who edited this episode
our fact checkers are michelle harris
robin palmer and julie beer
our copy editor is amy kolczak sound
design and original music for this
episode was done by romteen arab louie
and hansdale sue composed our theme
music this podcast is a production of
national geographic partners
whitney johnson is the director of
visuals and immersive experiences
susan goldberg is national geographic's
editorial director
and i'm your host amy briggs thanks for
listening and see y'all next time
[Music]
you